As Markiplier enters, he begins his journey through his many thoughts of Jack.
Mark sits down getting ready for his journey. He was going to confess love to Jack today.
But first, breakfast. Ah yes, the best meal of the day. Breakfast
As he sips from the mug of goodness, he looks at the cereal box and imagines Cornflakes X Markiplier fanfics.
Markiplier clears those thoughts from his mind and sets his cup down.
As Markiplier grabs the box of Corn Flakes, he wonders again about the possiblily of a Cornflakes X Markiplier fanic.
Markiplier smiles as his children pour out of the cornflake box.
"Come on my children, i just want to eat you!" Markiplier thinks, coaxing the cereal out of the box with an encouraging look on his face.
The wild Markimoo is content.
Markiplier opens the milk and imagines pouring it on Jack.
He continues twisting, imagining that same thought.
It opens and in Markimoo's dreaming state of mind, he accidentally spills some milk on the counter.
*Splish, sploosh*
Markiplier has not noticed the rogue milk.
The red haired cutie (In Jack's opinion) continues to poor milk until he is satisfied.
Markimoo is pleased.
"Thank you, dear friend." He says in his mind.
He puts the cap back on the milk. This is a perfect time for the narrator to add in some self advertising, so, I am Amytoadstool, you may find me in the comments. <3
Markiplier notices the stray milk. In his mind, he just burnt the world to a crisp and ate it with a smile on his face.
He carefully swipes away the milk...
...But gets bored and stops.
"Step away, biatch." Markiplier thinks, smiling in glee as he pushes his rival away from his presence.
He then draws his true love (Well, his OTHER true love) closer.
He grabs the mystical spoon.
*Slish!* Goes the spoon, delving into the depths of the milky ocean to search for hidden treasures.
Spoon brings his treasures to Markimoo The Master's mouth for inspection.
"Hmm, by complete scientific, i can decree that that is a cornflake!" Markimoo thinks, proud at his ability to know off by heart this treasure.
"How would this taste on Ja- Woah! Don't wanna go there yet, save that for tonight! " He thinks.
"Oh look, another Septiplier shipper!"
"So... Many.... Shippers..." He thinks with his majestic yet tiny brain.
"What a magnificent ship." He turns his head to the side, daydreaming about eyes and greenness.
Markiplier raises his eyebrow, thinking thoughts that the fans will never know.
"That's a good idea!" He smiles, nodding in acceptance at his past thoughts.
Spoon brings in another bounty of treasures.
"More cornflakes... I'm getting good at this!" :3
He shakes his head in pleasure.
*The wild Markimoo is content in his thoughts of a small leprechaun.*
"Leprechauns are sexy." Markiplier concludes.
"Aaah."
"Darkiplier shut up."
In deep thought...
"Yes, I'm sure he'd enjoy that."
Spoon brings in more treasure.
Nom, nom nom, and the treasure is gone!
In deep thought, yet again.
"Oh heeeelll nah! Fangirls, get out mah house!"
"Oh, its cupid."
"You do your job well." He thinks.
Looking for more cupids.
"Oh, your siblings....? Mother?" The markiplier is confuzzled, but smiles anyway.
"What a nice bow."
"Man, I sure am glad those dudes hit me and him."
Examines more of the treasure.
"I be bored now. JACK! ENTERTAIN ME!" He settles to drumming the table instead, knowing his senpai would not come to entertain him.
"Eh, he's irish!"  (No offence to irish pplz, luv u guys! With your adorable little accents, i just wanna keep you as pets! Oh... Sorry. :3)
"So, my nemesis, we meet again."
Markimoo picks up his nemesis and blows it, gently washing away the evil.
*Sounds of a quiet whirlpool can be heard.*
"Aaah."
Clonk.
He grabs Spoon and sends him on another adventure.
Spoon shoves the treasure in Markimoo's mouth.
Yum.
"Oh look, more Septiplier fan art!"
It's pretty good stuff.
"Oh if only they knew..."
"...Septiplier shippers across the globe would die because their life goal was complete."
Markiplier watches more and more Septiplier fan art appear on his ceiling.
"Come on guys, at least make me look better than a dying goat!"
"Ah, oh well."
More treasure.
Markiplier cruelly shoves Spoon under and above water, taunting him.
Markimoo inspects the treasure.
"Cornflakes!" Markimoo is proud.
"Hmm, more treasure!"
"Still cornflakes..."
*Strange sex noise.* (o.O)
Markimoo goes mad for a while and torments poor Spoonie.
More treasure.... (The Amytoadstool is bored. XD)
Content.
"Sorry if this is getting boring... I'm trying to entertain you! ARE YOU NOT ENTERTAINED?!" Yells the wild Amytoadstool.
"Ewwie! It tastes like sex..."
"Oh wait that's my tongue! Hehehe."
More tapping insues as he watches millions of Septiplier shippers scream as he says hi to Jack. (Me included. :3)
"Oooooh... That was an interesting fanfic..."
He is happy, as he managed to escape the wrath of the fanfic.
"Ahhh..... It's actually not that bad!" He smiles, continuing to read the fanfic.
"Oh look! A random inanimate object!"
"What a interesting object."
"Hmm? Oh, just fangirls swarming at my window."
"Hi there."
"Those guys are silly." He looks back at the inanimate object.
*wipe*
Good object.
Very good object.
"How'd cornflakes get my nudes?! Must admit though, i'm pretty hot."
Chewing ensues
Spoon delves in.
Markiplier inspects the treasure Spoon brought back... Again... For like the twelfth time...
"Back up biatch."
"Aaah, my friend."
Markiplier sips of the liquid bossness.
"Perfect... Jack must have made it."
Markiplier sips more of Le Liquid Bossness.
"Ahhh..." Markiplier resists the sudden urge to shout, "SPEEED ISSS KEEEEEEY!!!!"
He puts the glass back down.
Loud "Aaah!"
"Treasure? Mr. Spoon?" ("Oh dear god, please no...." Amytoadstool begs.)
"Wait a minute, come here you sly devil you." ("Yay!! Thank you mug!! <3)
Markiplier picks up the cup and sniffs it lightly.
*sip*
"Aaah"
*clonk*
*stir stir stir*
Markiplier inspects the- "DEAR GOD NO! NO, NO, NO, NO NO! NO, NO, NO, NO NO! NO, NO, NO, NO NO! NO, NO, NO, NO NO! NO, NO, NO, NO!" Narrator shouts.
Markiplier internally wades through more Septiplier fanfics and fan art.
He laughs because he is enjoying it.
*still laughing, now tapping however.*
Markiplier- "No! Don't you dare!" Markiplier ate cereal.
*mouth opens*
*nom.*
Ma- *Narrator glares* Cornflakes die.
He taps for a while.
He thinks of jack again, and then the arrangement tonight.
"Wait... I did remember to tell Jack to bring a spare pair of boxers, right?"
"Oh well! I'm sure he could guess from the text!"
Markiplier ferociously eats his cereal.
*crunch*
Markiplier annoys the crap out of everyone watching.
*shake shake shake*
*Crunch, crunch, crunch*
*sips up sweet liquid.*
Markiplier is happy.
"Oh no! He's choking!"
Mark hits the counter. Narrator calls Counter Abuse.
*thump*
Markiplier is no longer choking.
*Shakes shoulder.*
Nothing for quite some time.
Markimoo smiles.
Markiplier looks up, smiling at the hundreds of pictures of Jack painted in his mind.
"Oh well, I'm sure he loved me then too."
Markimoo sips his nemesis as Doggie barks in the background.
Markiplier turns
"SHUT UP PUPPEH!"
"Nooo, you're to cute to shut up! You're my little Jackiebo- I MEAN MARSHMALLOW... Totally..."
Bats at invisible fly
Markiplier begins to sip the coffee.
Markiplier pauses as he sifts through memories.
(Amytoadstool is sorry if you are unamused by these subtitles. She hopes you have a good day/night/one-night stand, I MEAN! Umm... One-night handstand..? Yah...)
Markiplier sees his favorite person. Or rather favorite pupper. (Thats so cute i have to leave it in)
With a smile, Markiplier puts his cup down.
*CLUNK* Markimoo gets up.
Mark leaves, his trolling complete. April Fools everbody~
*Awkward Silence fills the room*
Amytoadstool sighs in relief as she no longer has to worry about entertaining pplz.